[Aplausos]
[Música]
tengo un amigo canadiense que hace años
se fue de vacaciones a españa cuando
volvió lo primero que me dijo fue
fonseca no me puedo creer que tu país
esté en crisis todas las ciudades están
limpias calles bien pavimentadas
aeropuertos internacionales trenes de
alta velocidad vamos que madrid no tiene
nada que envidiarle a zúrich
y sabéis que es lo más gracioso pues que
tenía razón
a primera vista españa parece un país
rico sin embargo detrás de esa fachada
hay un país en crisis con unos índices
de paro nacho vidal jános y que está
pasando por uno de los momentos más
duros de su historia política
[Música]
destituyeron a mariano rajoy como
presidente del gobierno español con el
apoyo opositor el congreso aprobó una
moción de censura en su contra por
corrupción a no ser que viváis en una
cueva ya sabéis que españa acaba de
cambiar de gobierno pero no ha sido por
unas elecciones sino por una moción de
censura y que es una moción de censura
os preguntaréis pues básicamente que la
mayoría de los diputados del parlamento
propone un gobierno distinto como sabéis
en españa al igual que en muchos otros
países los ciudadanos no votamos al
presidente votamos a los diputados es
decir al poder legislativo y éstos a su
vez son los que eligen al líder del
ejecutivo
[Música]
dicho de otra forma que el parlamento
pone al presidente del gobierno pero
también lo puede quitar y en este caso
casi todos los partidos políticos de
españa se han puesto de acuerdo para
poner fin a la administración
conservadora del partido popular con
mariano rajoy a la cabeza pensadlo bien
hablamos de uno de los movimientos
políticos más complicados de la historia
el nuevo presidente del gobierno el
socialista pedro sánchez ha tenido que
poner de acuerdo a políticos de
izquierdas de derechas pero
independencia catalana y anti
independencia catalana todos ellos
tenían una sola cosa en común no estaban
dispuestos a mantener al gobierno de
mariano rajoy
[Música]
y os preguntaréis pero porque rajoy
tiene tantísimos haters por supuesto que
están los escándalos de corrupción pero
en honor a la verdad ninguno de estos
casos afectaba personalmente al
presidente y el partido socialista que
es quien toma el gobierno tampoco es que
esté limpio precisamente mientras tanto
el ya ex presidente del gobierno mariano
rajoy asegura que su gobierno ha sacado
a españa de la crisis de hecho estas
fueron sus palabras de despedida
[Música]
ha sido un honor dejar españa mejor que
como me la encontré mariano rajoy y por
eso la pregunta que nos hacemos hoy es
es eso cierto de verdad esta españa
mejor que hace 7 años es cierto que
españa está creciendo económicamente
pero sigue siendo el segundo país con
más desempleo de europa sólo superados
por grecia y ese avance económico está
siendo mucho más lento que en otros
países como irlanda por ejemplo
[Música]
así que hasta qué punto podemos decir
que rajoy ha sacado a españa de la
crisis hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes de que sigáis
viendo este vídeo tengo que hacer un
paréntesis porque este tema es
especialmente emocional para mí mucho
más que cataluña o cualquier otro tema
veréis hace muchos años que yo no voto
al partido popular no les vote en las
últimas elecciones y no creo que lo haga
en las próximas ahora bien mariano rajoy
fue mi primer jefe de hecho mi primer
trabajo a tiempo completo fue como
creativo en su equipo de campaña en la
sede de la calle génova y eso significa
que aunque no esté de acuerdo con muchas
de las cosas que ha hecho rajoy tengo
muchos y muy buenos recuerdos y muy
buenos amigos de esa época
dicho esto ahora sí vamos a ver un poco
de historia
los hombres de negro en el año 2002 se
crea la eurozona de repente españa
alemania francia y muchos otros países
tienen la misma moneda el euro
[Música]
y por supuesto los mismos tipos de
interés que son los que marca el banco
central europeo
todo esto tiene muchísimas ventajas al
tener una misma divisa un banco alemán
puede prestar dinero a una empresa
española en las mismas condiciones en
las que se lo prestaría a una empresa
alemana pero también tiene un riesgo si
españa quiebra ese banco alemán que
tiene deuda española quiebra también es
decir que los problemas de un país de la
eurozona se contagian a los otros países
y precisamente para evitar este riesgo
el euro tiene unas normas
una de ellas es que ningún país miembro
puede tener un déficit superior al 3% es
decir que no pueden gastar más de lo que
ingresan sin embargo vamos a avanzar
rápido en la historia con la crisis
financiera internacional un montón de
países europeos según den económicamente
y españa es uno de los que peor lo pasa
de repente la tasa de desempleo supera
el 20% y eso significa que el gobierno
recauda menos impuestos recordáis esos
trenes de alta velocidad y esos
aeropuertos internacionales que había en
españa pues resulta que hay que
seguirlos pagando y eso explica lo
siguiente
españa grecia e irlanda tuvieron los
mayores déficits fiscales de toda la
unión europea en 2012 para que os hagáis
una idea si el compromiso de déficit era
del 3% españa estaba en el 10%
eso significa que nadie se atrevía a
prestar dinero a este país y como ya
sabéis los veteranos seguidores de
visual político cuando los inversores de
un país no se fían de un país piden
intereses más altos veréis en la zona
euro tenemos un indicador que mide el
riesgo de impago de un país
si veis este vídeo desde españa seguro
que ya lo conocéis se llama la prima de
riesgo y funciona de la siguiente forma
damos por sentado que el bono más fiable
y por tanto con el interés más bajo es
el alemán así que comparamos el interés
que dan los bonos de los demás países
con los intereses del bono alemán y el
numerito que nos sale es la prima de
riesgo pues para que os hagáis una idea
en el año 2010 la deuda española tenía
una prima de riesgo de 50 puntos un año
más tarde estaba ya por los 250
los bonos españoles están en riesgo y el
contagio parece inminente y aquí es
cuando entran en escena los famosos
hombres de negro que es el nombre con el
que los periodistas españoles llamaban a
los funcionarios del banco central
europeo que exigían a los países
miembros de la eurozona que cumplieran
con sus compromisos fiscales es decir
que fueran más austeros en el gasto
[Música]
por ejemplo estos hombres de negro
fueron muy estrictos con irlanda y en
otros países como italia podríamos decir
que colocaron a un presidente del
gobierno cuyo trabajo era enderezar las
cuentas públicas y os preguntaréis qué
pasó en españa' que hicieron estos
hombres de negro en españa' pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver y creedme es muy
distinto de lo que contaron la mayoría
de los medios de comunicación
[Música]
el hombre tranquilo el 20 de noviembre
de 2011 el partido popular arrasa en las
elecciones mariano rajoy se convierte en
el líder con más capital político de
toda europa sólo superado por viktor
orbán en hungría el partido popular o
como se le conoce por sus siglas el pp
tenía el 53 por ciento de los escaños
del congreso y gobernaba en casi todas
las comunidades autónomas prácticamente
rajoy podría cambiar el nombre de españa
y pasar a llamar lamariano landia si
hubiera querido y que prometió rajoy en
la campaña electoral pues básicamente
rajoy le dijo al banco central europeo
los siguientes chavales no os preocupéis
que yo puedo controlar el déficit voy a
bajar los impuestos y hacer un montón de
reformas para que puedan surgir nuevas
empresas en españa estas empresas
crearán riqueza contratarán a gente y
como ganamos más dinero empezaremos a
recaudar más dinero básicamente todo
la campaña de rajoy se centraba en la
idea de bajar impuestos para que españa
fuera algo así como el silicon valley de
europa
vamos a bajar los impuestos eso nos
diferencia de todos los demás que dicen
que van a subirlo el partido popular
quiere bajar los impuestos para que todo
cambie su intención es no subir los
impuestos derecho para mejorar la stampa
el pp sacó un vídeo publicitario donde
explicaban todo este programa económico
vídeo que por cierto estuvo escrito
dirigido y dibujado por este menda que
veis aquí tal cual como lo oís como
haremos las cosas de otra manera el
gobierno debe establecer un marco en el
que las empresas puedan ser competitivas
si aliviamos la presión fiscal y
modernizamos nuestro modelo impositivo
por ejemplo haciendo que pymes y
autónomos no tengan que pagar el iva
hasta que no hayan cobrado las facturas
conseguiremos que tengan una mayor
liquidez sin embargo mis queridos amigos
de visual política una cosa es lo que se
dice en campaña electoral y otra lo que
se hace una vez se llega al gobierno
este gobierno se ve obligado a una
subida
temporal de determinados impuestos en
los primeros meses de rajoy el gobierno
subió todos los impuestos posibles y
esas reformas tan maravillosas se
quedaron en bonitas palabras desde luego
a los votantes entre los que me incluyo
no nos hizo ninguna gracia pero eso no
es lo peor lo peor es que esos
inversores internacionales que estaban
expectantes por ver lo que hacía rajoy
perdieron toda la confianza de la noche
a la mañana
la economía española está en una crisis
enorme después de la degradación de su
crédito
básicamente el bono de deuda español
pasó a considerarse como 'bono basura'
esa prima de riesgo de la que os hablaba
antes superó la satánica cifra de los
666 puntos y muchos bancos españoles
estaban al borde de la quiebra nadie en
el mercado estaba dispuesto a comprar
deuda española y los que lo hacían
exigían unos intereses nacho vidal ya
nos españa estaba a punto de quebrar y
eso significa que nadie podría pagar los
sueldos de los funcionarios ni los
hospitales ni los colegios había llegado
el momento de los hombres de negros
españa acepta un rescate de europa para
los bancos en apuros y os preguntaréis
en qué consistía este rescate pues
básicamente europa prestaba dinero a
precio de amigo para rescatar a las
cajas de ahorros españolas que son algo
así como bancos públicos que estaban
quebrados y que podían llevarse por
delante a todo el país a cambio estos
hombres de negro exigían que el gobierno
hiciera recortes de gasto y aquí es
donde llega el gran pulso de mariano
rajoy lo que bien podría llamarse la
rajoy o mick básicamente mariano rajoy
se cruzó de brazos y dijo a ver qué pasa
aquí señores del banco central europeo-
mira veis estos tres delitos pues podéis
empezar a leer entrelíneas la teoría de
rajoy era que tarde o temprano el banco
central europeo terminaría comprando los
bonos de deuda de españa sin apenas
pedir un tipo de interés alto
[Música]
con ese dinero españa podía seguir como
estaba sin tener que hacer reformas y
porque iba a comprar deuda el banco
central europeo pues muy sencillo españa
es la cuarta economía más grande de
europa y nadie la va a dejar caer y así
es como pasaron los meses el paro
continuaba creciendo la prima de riesgo
seguía creciendo y la economía seguía
cayendo y el gobierno del pp lejos de
hacer reformas para que se crearan
empresas
hacía todo lo contrario
queréis un ejemplo os doy un ejemplo el
anterior presidente del gobierno josé
luis rodríguez zapatero que era de
centroizquierda aprobó una ley para
liberalizar muchos servicios
profesionales como los taxistas pues
bien una de las primeras cosas que hizo
rajoy fue dar marcha atrás en esta
liberalización y permitir que los
taxistas sigan estando protegidos por el
gobierno gracias a eso empresas como
uber o herby apenas se han podido
implantar en españa y os preguntaréis
funcionó este pulso terminó la unión
europea pasando por el aro y la
respuesta es que sí
what it takes to presión de euro
[Música]
supermario al rescate durante meses el
presidente del banco central europeo
mario draghi decía que no iba a acceder
al chantaje de españa' básicamente rajoy
exigía que europa imprimirá más euros
con los que comprar deuda española
[Aplausos]
en otras palabras que los países ricos
como alemania o finlandia le regalaran
dinero a españa sin ningún coste
político en fin que no parece un trato
muy justo verdad sin embargo en este
caso rajoy tenía razón
españa era demasiado grande como para
dejarla caer
el bc estaría listo para comprar bonos
débiles de italia y españa- para que os
hagáis una idea el 25 por ciento de la
deuda española actualmente está en manos
del banco central europeo y esas
palabras de mario draghi diciendo que
haría lo que fuera necesario para
rescatar al euro fueron algo así como un
conjuro mágico de un día para otro la
prima de riesgo española empezó a caer
de repente los inversores volvían a
comprar bonos de deuda porque sabían que
tenían el respaldo del bc y así es como
españa se ha podido seguir endeudando
como si no existiera mañana
para que os hagáis una idea este país
debe más del cien por cien de su
producto interior bruto mientras tanto
el resto de países de europa han seguido
creciendo desde el año 2012 hasta hoy
alemania se ha convertido en la mayor
potencia exportadora del mundo la
economía de eeuu ha vuelto a crecer ya
crear empleo y china ha pasado de ser la
fábrica del mundo a ser un nuevo mercado
donde vender productos en otras palabras
que todos los países europeos están
creciendo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
lógicamente eso también incluye a grecia
italia y por supuesto españa sin embargo
para mariano rajoy cualquier buena
noticia era suficiente como para poderse
colgar una medalla
[Aplausos]
rajoy españa ha superado la crisis en
tiempo récord estamos ya en el año 2015
año en el que vuelve a ver elecciones y
el gobierno decide celebrar la salida de
la crisis con una bajada de impuestos en
plena campaña electoral y ya que no
adivináis qué pasó tan solo un año
después de que rajoy volviera a ganar
las elecciones exacto
rajoy vuelve a subir los impuestos en
2017 el nuevo gobierno tendrá que
recortar al menos 15.000 millones el
déficit como os podéis imaginar esto de
subir o bajar impuestos dependiendo de
si hay o no hay elecciones no es
precisamente la mejor política para
atraer empresas si a eso le sumamos la
burocracia que sigue exactamente igual
que antes de rajoy y todos los problemas
territoriales es fácil entender por qué
españa sigue teniendo un 16 por ciento
de paro mientras otros países como
estonia o irlanda que también tuvieron
recesiones brutales
están mucho mejor ahora que hace 10 años
españa apenas ha cambiado por supuesto
que esta no es la única razón por la que
ha ganado la moción de censura contra
mariano rajoy podríamos hablar de la
corrupción y de muchas otras cosas que
habréis visto en otros medios de
comunicación pero personalmente no creo
que este gobierno se pueda colgar
ninguna medalla en gestión económica en
cualquier caso
ahora es vuestro turno y nota le pondría
is a la presidencia de mariano rajoy
pensáis que españa ha dejado atrás la
crisis económica podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y antes de
despedirme tengo que daros las gracias a
los que nos habéis apoyado en patrón
hemos logrado nuestro primer objetivo en
menos de una semana y en unos días
publicaremos el primer vídeo que ha sido
posible gracias a vuestra colaboración
muchas gracias y como siempre
suscribiros a visual politics si no lo
habéis hecho ya si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]